Hôm nay, đồng tham mêu chiều nguyên của anh Hanoi, Rồi Xea cho biết,
sau nay theo dựa phương chưa đến đã phòng ít nhất một tên lời đạn đạo khủng sách định về vụ biệt đa bàn.
Theo Rồi Xea, con đội Hanoi của đàn phần tích các thủng số kỹ thuật như chúng lại và tập bán của tên lời đạn đạo được phòng lên này,
tuy nhiên chưa cùng cấp thêm chỉ tiếp tụi về loại in lời hải thập bán.
Trong gì đó, con đội Hanoi của những định bán đầu, có việc hệ được phòng đi là tên lời đạn đạo tập ngán,
được bán đi từ phía năng của Chiu Tien.
Tên lời đạn đạo tập ngán,
tên lời của Chiu Tien không gây ra thị thái gì.
Ngày xò khi có thông tin về vụ phòng, tên thủ tưởng nhận bán xa này ta cây chi.
Đá chỉ đạo vụ quốc phòng nước này nhân trong thủ thập và phần tích thông tin,
tính hành thác bệnh pháp đạn bảo anh nình, anh toàn cho nhận bán,
đồng thời cho biết sẽ hợp tác chật chạy với Mỹ và hành Quốc trong đổi phó với các phụ thử tin lời của Chiu Tien.
Đây là vụ phòng tin lời đổ tiên của Chiu Tien, kể tức khi chính phủ của tổng thống hành Quốc liên trên biên nhận trước bảo thằng sau năm nay.
Lận thế này, giễn ra trước thêm chuyển thông hành của của tổng thủ ý đò này chăm và chủ tịch trưng thuốc tập cập bình,
nhân dì phổi gị thượng định à phách, tổ chức tại thành phố nghiệm chủ,
tương ngày 3,5 tháng người đến ngày 1,5 môi tháng 1 môi tự đây.